so ordered Senate is adjourned on Friday
Democratic party house managers
concluded their opening arguments
against Donald Trump over three sessions
they meticulously present of their case
the Trump abused the office of the
president in an attempt to gain a
competitive advantage against his
Democratic rival Joe Biden by attempting
to blackmail the Ukrainian president
president Trump tried the cheat he got
caught and then he worked hard to cover
it up
only his will goes he is a dictator this
must not stand and that is why another
reason he must be removed from office
and that the president obstructed
Congress as it probed his alleged
wrongdoing by withholding evidence and
intimidating potential witnesses it's
simple the president abused the powers
entrusted in him by the American people
in a scheme to suppress evidence escape
accountability and orchestrate a massive
cover-up and he did so in plain sight
and his obstruction remains ongoing now
it's up to the president's lawyers to
make their case we're gonna rabat and
refute and we're gonna put on an
affirmative case tomorrow
unlike the Democrats the White House
lawyers are not expected to use all of
their time there will be a short morning
session on Saturday but their arguments
are expected to start in earnest on
Monday Donald Trump has made it clear
that he wants his case made in weekday
TV prime time and not during the weekend
the White House will argue that it was
in the national interest to ask the
Ukrainian president for an investigation
into Biden and his son and potential
conflicts of interest why did hunter
Biden hold a lucrative position at an
allegedly corrupt Ukrainian energy
company despite having no expertise in
the area while his father was vice
president why they opened up the door as
white as a double-door on the hunter
Biden Joe Biden burr is my issue I guess
they figured that was it their way of
getting ahead of it we will address it
in addition they will argue that it is
the
Democrats who are abusing their power as
they seek to overturn the results of the
2016 election and influence the next and
violate the constitutionally mandated
separation of powers between Congress
and the president the sense here is that
it's still very unlikely that any
witnesses will be called so the White
House is still on track for an acquittal
of the president before the State of the
Union address on February the 4th she
avert an C al Jazeera Washington